hallo mein name ist locker und wir gehen
heute wieder auf ein paar sinnlose
webseiten ich habe das ganze schon mal
aufgenommen das völlig euch mal hier das
könnt ihr euch nach dem video gleich mal
anschauen oder gar nicht weil ihr denkt
ich bin ein blöder aber auch egal wir
fangen auf jeden fall an mit einer ju
geklärt jetzt mal ganz kurz das prinzip
dieser website geht es darum die klicken
auf kreis und kommune website
das war's also take me to use this
website ließ wir kommen auf das einzige
was ich hier machen kann
in navis website ließ nils lab heißt wie
diese website ist nicht verfügbar
connection keine haut neu laden und
schon wieder ist die website nicht
verfügbar da seht ihr schon freunde das
klappt ja geklappt super aber wir lassen
uns davon natürlich nicht unterkriegen
sondern holen uns eine neue users
webseite heißt es in dieser zeit noch
den widerling schon beim ersten teil
ich muss zum friseur habe meine haare
sind die zulagen wieder auftrieb und
sind aufstieg an alle die den ersten
fall gewinnen musst du bereit kamen dann
neue webseiten dazu und ich weiß aber
auch schon mal mit dabei war man das ist
doch nicht war als ob diese entwickler
so umland 5 es sind nur die gleichen
webseiten man wie klicken jetzt mal so
lange drauf ist
[Musik]
die medien ja in lausanne herbert der
u23 oder bap ok damit probiere ich mal
penis hunter displays wurde nichts
ok dann ein smiley per handy hier ist
ich gehe jetzt mal ein youtube passt
verteilen trainiert als seinen kanal
1999 hd hunter let's play
natürlich brennt pannock lodes man ich
kann man mit so einem behinderten
scheint einfach beantwortet das mit
denen oder ja wow vdm
das ist auch neue alter wien vom wir
beobachten jetzt einfach mal einfach
ganz oben hier den ihr der volt darunter
wird da hob flip groll darüber das war's
also das ist das erste wo ich wirklich
sagen muss dicke props an den entwickler
dieser webseite das ist ja tatsächlich
mal richtig heiß ich dachte nur das
wären so einzelne zusammengepackt
kästchen so in etwa aber es ist
tatsächlich einfach alles miteinander
fackel brennt im kaller website okay die
hat mir letzte mal auch schon mal das
einmal die farbe wechseln und gemüse
nur tot
[Musik]
ja gehen wieder nicht wie sie sich
anziehen das ist wie so ein club aber
ich weiß zwar nicht was das ganze soll
aber es macht tatsächlich einen
heidenspaß ein kleiner pixel website
aber wir sind wieder auf dem dach der
bestbezahlte die hatten wir letztes mal
ja auch schon alles klar
die website besteht aus flexibler fleck
switcher flex liga das bild hat mir
gleich auch schon beim letzten mal
müssen versuchen die behinderten website
heißt giant bedford also die fledermaus
[Musik]
damit haben wir jetzt absolut wieder den
übrigen kiefer jetzt macht doch mal
diese scheiße hier weckt damit haben
jetzt letzte website wieder ein
kompletter niveauvolles ende gefunden
wir haben eigentlich niveauvollen beim
einem bios oder wenn es euch gefallen
dann würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freundin wollte dass das noch mal machen
mit einer anderen website also mit
komplett anderen webseiten dann zeige
ich mir mit einer bewertung soll ich
vielleicht mal stift essen dann zeigt
dass man mit ibm oder wurde letztes auch
wieder gesagt ich bin der meister der
autos ich bin der beste abmoderation
könig der matches